so hello welcome to the session on
service mesh we might be in the smallest
room but we filled it so thank you my
name is Rob Crowley I'm a principal
consultant for ratify previous to that I
was the technical lead for API is an
authentication at bankwest so the vast
amount of my career has been designing
and building distributed systems so this
is a topic that's very close to my heart
so we're gonna start with a bit of a pop
quiz
so who has heard of the service mesh
pattern this is good probably a bit more
of a tricky question though is anyone
running a service machine production
excellent that's the first time I've
seen a hand awesome but that's cool for
the rest of us that's why we're here
so we're here to learn a little bit more
about the pattern but I don't want you
to just come today and get an idea about
this was some cool piece of tech but not
really be sure how to apply it to your
context so what we want to do today is
have an understanding about why is the
service mesh even a thing what category
of problems does it help address and
also they can give you the understanding
to be able to take a back to your
organization's and say yes this is
something that can help and in what
context we're then going to contrast
service meshes to other patterns of
practices that we had over the years so
API gateways and a good ol friend the
Interphone service bar so we've got to
see how the certain similarities between
these but also the differences and sort
of the same end goal but achieved a
different way technology is all well and
good but what really excites me is the
things that I've enabled us to do how
does it change the way we can do our
work so what we're going to look at then
is how service measures can give access
to a whole host of really advanced
capabilities that were previously rement
of tech luminaries like Google alone but
now actually brings a lot of these
capabilities within the reach of mere
mortals most of all I would love to
start a conversation or continue a
conversation about service measures in a
city technical
unity and realistically we only have an
hour together so disclaimer I will not
be able to turn every single person in
this room into an expert in that time
boss boss
if I can inspire you just enough to go
and learn more about this when you leave
that would be an amazing outcome for me
so a very smart person once told me that
every good presentation should have a
story and so this presentation has a
story too and it's a love story it's a
love story of wood service a met service
B and this is back in the 1950s these
are baby boomer services and they're
both deployed on the same host and they
talk every day and because they're on
the same machine it's amazing this
conversations happening it's very
reliable they're having an absolute
wonderful time but good they've never
last do they as part of a digital
transformation service B is REE hosted
suddenly all of these conversations that
they could have before it's not cross
process they're on different machines
how will this love story end you ask
that's okay distributed computing is
easy isn't it it's not gonna be that
hard you know this will be okay no
long-distance relationships are tough so
first of all before service I could just
call service B I'm gonna respond sir
instantly now suddenly it's having to
write these love letters and it sends
them in the post it doesn't get a reply
then what you do DC needy G's just keep
sending the letters no we're not we're
gonna like hold back a bit I will
definitely reply at some point but
there's suddenly all this doubt right
and at the same time because these are
no two separate systems the ability for
a tip pen his love letters and send them
across its completely divorced from the
ability of the other service to
consumers so again we could have this
amount of traffic downstream without the
other service being able to consume it
and the packet loss happens potential
degradation of you
services as well so all this reliable
ability that we took for granted we were
running in process
suddenly evaporates and back in the
1990s Peter Dutch and a number of his
collaborators at Sud highlighted exactly
some of these problems we named them the
eight fallacies of distributive
computing and by naming them as
fallacies it makes us take account of
them so these are things such as the
network it is not reliable you know so
the network you know we assume done of
these when we're running in process but
it's not so we have to take account for
that latency is not zero there's a delay
speed of light 300,000 kilometers per
second but that's not instant that's
still 50 milliseconds latency between
Perth where I work and live and Sydney
that's even on them exited network if
you take you to cut all the other hops
and routers then that's get delayed
again so we have all these other
problems that we didn't have to face in
these more basic computing models and
let's see what actually happens so what
a previously alluded to was flow control
so flow control is the ability for one
service to detect the amount of traffic
that it's sending downstream and then
modify the amount it sends such as it
doesn't overload the downstream service
and again we're back in the 1950s so you
know back at this time when computers
were relatively rare
it was the application developers
ourselves that would have had to solve
this problem so within the business
logical buy service I would suddenly
have to account for did the message ever
arrive
do I have to buffer it to then send
downstream again what if I said it twice
what have I said that out of order
all of this reliable delivery concerned
again was part of the services
themselves and even with this warm flow
control example was suddenly kind of
thinking oh my goodness this
relationship is doomed
whoa this distributed computing thing is
just a little bit higher than we might
have initially suspected but there's
more so again in three broad categories
of reliability observability and traffic
management these are just umbrella terms
that they in themselves hold a huge
amount of nuances so with traffic
management we have
little balancing how do i distribute my
trophy across all of the nodes of
availability pool but maybe that's not
good enough maybe you need to have
latency aware low balancing such that
you can route your traffic to the nose
who can best respond in a timely fashion
remember we're not all living in what
data said ready board we have service
discovery so again maybe DNS would have
been sufficient before but though we
have systems that are spread
geographically we have to do what
multiple environments we want to do
advanced things like canary releases
suddenly DNS is a sufficient anymore we
have access control so who can actually
call this message who is it for we then
have concerns around per request routing
so do we want to apply any overrides
there do we want to you know chaos
engineering so inject false so do we
want to shadow traffic a lot of concerns
before that you will be starting in to
traffic management this quite a bit
there and observability so a
characteristic of our systems to see how
well we can understand this operation
and production and we want to know
things like success rates latency log so
again remember we're looking to do
latency aware low balancing requests
volumes and that's just individual
requests at the same time we might want
to paint a picture of a business
transaction that spans multiple systems
so you might have heard of open tracing
and Zipkin these are all things as well
where we want to get the health of a
business flow throughout our myriad
services and then reliability our good
old friends the health checks circuit
breakers as defined by Michael Nagai
than is in his book release it so again
to prevent cascading failure across your
network retry policies so again in this
love letter if I get a return to sender
is it safe to send it again because
we're all building idempotent services
rod timeouts are good or friendly
distributed systems so how do we make
sure that our timeouts are generous
enough such that valid traffic doesn't
get rejected but at the same time tight
enough so you're not risking resource
consumption and again causing
reliability issues across the network so
what first started reading through these
I have wow this distributed computing
thing is a lot harder than we thought
but well there's will there's a way and
how do we make long-distance
relationships work
so with flow control what happened is
this went away from being the domain of
the application developer and rather
we've pushed that down into the network
layer so no longer is a business logic
cluttered with these reliability
concerns but now we can just again we
take this for granted today we call this
TCP like we're standing on the shoulders
of giants until a BT mentioned it
through the keynotes as well installed
by Thunder which was a bit unfortunate
but this is absolutely amazing because
one that lets us do is all of this
concern about traffic routes that it
just happens it's guaranteed delivery
it's in order you get acknowledgment
somebody sends from there but we don't
have to worry about it and I can look at
TCP and how it plays into that network
layer so again at the physical layer
we're just dealing with raw bytes going
across the wire so at the data link
layer is then reliable communication or
transmission of packets data frames
between two computers at the IP level we
have ipv4 and ipv6 this is how we do
routing so addressing so when you put it
in how do I actually know where the
traffic's gonna get sent there that
therefore we have transport so this is
again where TCP lives this is the
guaranteed delivery moving up we have we
have sessions so again rather you know
you can say TLS lives there you can
possibly say it lives it across a number
of other layers as well and this is also
where WebSockets would live so there's
nothing magical about WebSockets they're
just TCP running within a browser
security context and then up here up at
their seven this is where we do at the
vast amount of our program we just say
HDB Clyde dot send and it happens
magically but there is all this
engineering that happens under the hood
and this is just one example of how we
solved for flow control but history ever
has a habit of repeating itself and
again the system that we're building
today are a lot more complicated but
even with these advanced capabilities
that we need to support these systems
what were you getting want to do is
abstract them away from the application
developers themselves so we could focus
on business logic and this is where we
came up with a stellar idea of an
enterprise service bus and these are
actually a great idea at the time so
again we can have all these different
services some of them could be AMQP so
that could be soap maybe some forward
JSON of HTTP one might even be a rest
service through those and then each of
these services will have an adapter and
then what we could do is we we would
then have reliable delivery aren't any
transformations of business logic
applied in the advice service boss and
this actually seems like a great model
so again we have all this
interconnection between our services but
again there's always trade-offs so what
are the companies that worked for ade
London I was parent of an integration
team we were rock stairs first 50
integrations we were smashing about we
had all these different services and you
know we were absolutely amazing at it
and so when we were finished
congratulating ourselves there was
suddenly looked at it was like we're up
to a couple of hundred of these
integrations and then we started slowing
down so in like typical sort of like
fred brooks you know methodology we just
like to more people in the team and
something we were a team of ten so that
made Friday night drinks absolutely lots
of fun but again not from actually
getting through the water ice because
the trade-offs with this is an intimate
service most first of all is a single
point of failure so you're gonna have
one of them and this is not only from an
infrastructure point of view but also
from a delivery centralized team so then
we we formed the constraint on our
company's ability to deliver so they
could only deliver as quick as our team
could move so again a single point of
failure both from an operational but
also an architecture perspective and the
reason what we slowed down is because we
couldn't keep like the mental model of
all these different integrations and we
couldn't keep them separated so again
regression testing became a massive
overhead force and in the end it
actually had the opposite effect so we
put it in to be able to move faster but
fast forward a couple years and it was
actually the very thing that was holding
us back
and so then after a number of years
looking at this we we as an industry
said there has to be a different way of
doing it there has to be some
alternatives then a lot of thinking
around cloud native came up in cloud
days it was really the confluence of a
number of techniques and technology so
first of all we have DevOps and its core
DevOps is about continuous learning
improvement and to be able to have fast
feedback loops and be able to take an
empirical approach to delivery we also
have continuous delivery then so again
practice is about being able to do that
safely and fast and rather than making
god-filled decisions we can actually put
something out based on data and move
from there but of course I thought that
we would still be dealing with VMs so
again very costly slow to move
cumbersome so again on the other side we
then had first of all micro services so
how can we actually have small discrete
pieces of business functionality of
business behavior which can then change
at their own pace also the sales pitch
goes and then we have containers
themselves so again this is actually a
really nice package because then I can
have a very small service with a very
small packaging format and I have an
absolutely amazing developer experience
all the way from the local to its
production and there's some people in
the room that are probably thinking
though what happens service a and
service B did they make it I'm glad to
say they did and they had micro service
babies they're everywhere but just like
babies this picture is a little bit
messy right so previous we had service a
and service B and one nice little line
between the two this is madness there's
integrations happening absolutely
everywhere and it's really complicated
rod and this is something I'm not sure
as an industry we really expected but
the operability of micro service
architectures is you know quite high in
terms of the challenge they represent so
one of the key things though when I say
service
is a services business logic plus data
with the ESB model a lot of the business
logic actually left the services them
themselves and actually went into the
central platform as well it's want to
talk about an API an API is an entry
point into a service but with the
service themselves you want to have the
data and the business logic close
together live together because it's
changed together and this is what the
movement about guerrilla SOA really came
from so instead of having all this logic
within the central enterprise service
boss it then said the logic should sit
with the endpoints the services
themselves and the pipes in between them
to be dumb like that's a really key
point from there so again getting the
log back into the services where they
should be but once we've done that a lot
of the great value that we had from the
Enterprise Service bus before in terms
of life discovery routing circuit
breakers as well that's suddenly again
just like back in the 1950s it became
the remit of the application developer
again so again what we just want to be
able to focus on business logic we then
now have to take advice of service
discovery so again how do I route my
messages to all the different clients so
client silo balancing as well so circuit
breaker is again how do I prevent
cascading failures so if I have a
downstream service and it hasn't
responded successfully in number of
times why am I still sending traffic to
it can I add then provide a fallback to
my own consumers but one of the things
from there is we often had this this
phrase like purported about micro
services is that you can write them in
whatever language you want and again so
about the language that suits the
particular problem but service discovery
circuit breakers like there are actually
very complicated things and in fact
there's libraries available for most of
them so in the jabber space of the JVM
you might have heard of histories from
Netflix so I think these are very
complicated or pali in the.net space so
you don't be writing these yourself but
it's suddenly if I want to you know void
my news micro service and Julia whatever
Oh but someone hasn't written a circuit
breaker library for me
can I now use it so a lot of these
things as well is your your ability to
choose that languages often constrained
by the libraries that are actually
available for it so again it's this
whole thing of steady got giants so
there's an what this actually leads a
lot to if you look at companies like
Netflix again they say that you can
again to their teams you can write your
languages you know your services and
whatever like would you choose but if
you write them in Java you will get all
of this amazing help if you write them
in a different language which you're
absolutely free to do you'll have to
write it all yourself guess what happens
so I was a couple years ago I was over a
philosophy in Santa Clara and an
absolutely amazing conference and the
Netflix engineer that I spoke to he
described as getting in the trough that
everyone just gets in the trough so
while they still had a micro service
architecture they definitely didn't have
the freedom that was often touted our
micro services but again what can we do
to overcome this so before if we had all
of this concern being when the
application services themselves then
what we said aha what we could do is
every service could have its own
dedicated side care proxy which could
run across process so an example of this
is Netflix pranit and again all of these
languages again so if I want to take
advantage of the Netflix OSS that but I
don't want to write services that run at
the JVM I could have this run in the JVM
and I can get advantage of all of those
within that side care proxy and between
the services you're just talking
language agnostic protocols so HTTP and
because they're actually again deploy to
the same host we know that that
connection is reliable between these two
services and then what we can do is all
ingress and egress from those containers
is via the side care proxy that's really
nice so we can we've encapsulated a lot
of this logic as well so another example
of this is Airbnb synapse if you're
looking for this as well so this is
quite a powerful pattern and in fact in
in many ways this is the central idea or
an abler for a service mesh as well so
this is what a better micro services
world could look like so we know how we
am
we still have the same interconnections
between all of our services but they all
flow through a dedicated side care proxy
though and again that handles a lot of
the complicated business logic of a
reliable transmission of messages and
again our services themselves could
actually be focused on the business
matters at hand so onto the service
measure parrot itself so this is a quote
from William Morgan who is the CEO of
buoyant so Boyd's our company who
created link OD what are the first
commercially available or available
service meshes and he described it as
this so a service mesh is a dedicated
infrastructure layer so in the similar
way you can be thinking not the concern
of the application developers themselves
but again part of the underlying
platform and it's responsible for
reliable delivery of messages and it's
typically implemented as a lightweight
network proxies so again the side care
properties that we saw the previous
diagram and the point as well at the end
is without the application needing to be
aware so to paraphrase you should not
have to change your existing system to
be able to take advantage of the service
mesh so from there so long as you are
talking in a language agnostic protocol
HTTP and the traffic is routed through
it then you could take advantage of it
but that's one of the key principles so
a really important point now is a
service mesh is not magic it doesn't
give us the ability to do things we
could never ever do in the industry
before what it does allow us to do is
shift where that responsibility lies so
that could be cross process outside of
the service itself and then within that
dedicated infrastructure layer
comprising the service mesh and the
surface mesh comprises two main parts
first of all it has a data plane and a
control plane so the data plane is the
path that the traffic takes so the
traffic that flows out of your
particular service
through its proxy and into the next
proxy anything that's on the path of the
traffic flow between two services but
there's also a control plane which we
haven't looked at or hasn't appeared in
one of the diagrams today and it's it's
out-of-band with the rest of the service
mesh but what it allows us to do is
instead of separate proxies that are
completely isolated we can then send
instructions to the service mesh control
plane and it will then push that policy
out to all of those side care proxies so
what we have is again at one place that
we can configure all of these services
but again have those applied in each
water beside care proxies lists to each
service and this is a massively powerful
capability because just like with the
ESB it provides the same authoritative
source of policies so there's one place
to configure this there's one source of
truth but unlike an ESB where the
control plane and the data plane is one
if the control plane went down that's
absolutely fine it's just that your side
care properties wouldn't receive policy
updates for a period of time but what
we've done is we've taken the
configuration off the critical path so
we no longer have that central point of
friction and possible failure so I know
what you're thinking though we should
side care everything right this is a
great quote from Kelsey Hightower from
Google and it's really one of these
things to say focus on the basics first
so attaching side cares for an
application there's no value in it until
you're actually facing those problems as
well if there's a simple thing of just
including that in one of your services
first start with this when the
operability of those services become
sufficiently sufficiently taxing on you
that's when you can start investing in
techniques such as this
okay so so far we've been talking rather
abstractly about the pattern itself so
let's get a little bit more concrete so
we're gonna talk about sto which is a
service mesh from Google and a number of
others in the consortium as well and I'm
back in August this had a really big
milestone so released v wood so that
that's again after like a number of
years of development so you absolutely
huge milestone and if anyone's wondering
why there's a boat there sto is the
Greek for sailing so again there's a bit
of a lake just like kubernetes is helps
but so there seems to be a bit of a
theme there and it's do comprises a
number of parrots so first of all
looking at the data plane so it co uses
envoi from lift as its side care proxy
so again there's a invoice itself is a
huge thing there's actually a conference
around it now as well and Matt Klein
blogs a lot about it as well and it
supports a huge raft of capabilities and
for interest service communication or
inter service communication we have HTTP
1.1 B of HTTP - you could have G or PC
or really any derivative or like a pube
drift over TCP as well so it gives a
huge amount of flexibility and also you
can have mutual TLS between them if you
want as well it's do splits the control
plane into three main parts each with a
separate remit or responsibility so
first of all we have a pilot so this is
what you would have seen in the previous
examples as well of this is what we
actually use to push config out to each
one of our side cares we then have mixer
so mixer gathers telemetry from each one
of those services as well to actually
feel some of our observability concerns
so success rates latency so again this
is where we also do policy checks to
make sure that the correct version is
applied to each one of these services as
well and then we also have Citadel so
you can think of Citadel as the
certificate authority within each do so
again if you have mutual TLS between
your services it will be responsible for
issuing those certificates
okay so right there let's take a really
quick look ass sto and in action and our
example domain is pretty basic so first
of all you would have seen with service
a calling service B but then as part of
the demos which we'll go through we'll
look at releasing multiple versions of
service C so we have version one we have
version two which has just gone into
production and we have this version
three that we're working on and
throughout the course of this talk we'll
hope that we'll get at the prod Road and
then we also have service D as well
which is called by v2 of observa so
again this is the solar model for each
one of the examples we'll dig into a bit
more about what we're looking to achieve
and then I'll show you it in action as
well but first of all what would what
we'll do is we'll take a real quick look
in in kubernetes for this particular
application as well so for each one of
the pods that we have in kubernetes we
have again one for each one of these
services and what you'll notice as well
is that each of them say ready to of two
so that means there's two containers
within each pod so again no prizes for
guessing that one of them will be the
service itself and the other one will be
the sto proxy so we can see from these
is that each one of them will have the
sto property which will handle the
ingress and egress of traffic from those
services as well so what we'll do here
is we'll just send a really quick amount
of traffic to go Truths he can just see
a little bit of what we can do to update
the policies
so from here if anyone's familiar with
with the curl alias with empower she'll
have actually removed it so this is just
like Roy Carroll adjustable power she'll
go across the top ten and what we'll do
here is just there's an infinite loop
where we can send traffic and what we
should see here is to do oh my goodness
that sir but so what we can see here is
all of the traffic just being echoed
back in version one of that service so
what we can do here now is update this
traffic to now send it to v2 now what
we'll see in this demo is that without
releasing that service or deploying that
service again we now see that all the
traffic is being routed to v2
I wouldn't might say Rob that's a pretty
basic example but what we should be
seeing already is that could be a canary
release so right now I just did it as an
100 percent traffic swap well you could
say send two percent of traffic to that
then send five percent of traffic to
that so you can change all of these
policies dynamically without having to
redeploy your services but again like I
said take it school in and of itself but
what's really exciting about it is the
things that now enables us to do and
testing and production got a bit of a
bad rap for a while so what I'm talking
about here is not
I only test in production but again it's
a reflection of the types of systems
that we're building now so in
traditional testing we might have a
particular system running in a test
environment which might not be
represented about production ok fine
with a certain set of data at a certain
time with a certain configuration and
we think we think that gives us
confidence to be able to push it it's
reduction and it won't fail its
massively highlights false confidence
the cause and effect between something
happening in our system and actually
being able to trace that back that's
just not feasible anymore so we're
dealing with the scenarios of unknown
unknowns now and this is really the
shift from being able to focus on
robustness insofar as how do we handle
at avoid errors in our systems to
resilience so unplanned how can our
systems when faced with an error respond
in a positive manner so again testing a
production absolutely a great idea but
the trick is doing it safely
so there's luckily over the last year
and there's been a lot of great material
that's being released about this so this
is a picture from Cindy she inherited
from Facebook and she's documented
testing in production having a number of
discrete phases so at deploy time our
release time and then post release when
we actually have a product running so
for the purposes of this talk I'm gonna
make a very clear distinction between a
deployed service and they released
service a service is released once it's
receiving any production traffic prior
to that it's just deployed and again at
each one of these phases we can apply a
certain set of techniques so we can do
integration tests pretty classic we can
do low tests we can also do traffic
shadowing so again we'll look at that
here the demo in a second as well once
we're actually receiving production
traffic we can do things like narrow
releases we could do monitoring we can
do traffic shaping we can also do pilot
releases to a subset of users as well to
feature flags and then once we have in
production as well then we're into the
space of how do we do sampling how do we
do tracing again how do we actually
minimize the cost of ownership of our
systems well maximize the value we get
for all us
okay so traffic mirroring so what we're
looking from here is often with the test
environments that we have even if we can
get the environments right often the
data is the tricky part do you grab your
production data do you try to D
identifier or you just create this or
like sample set of data as well and
again the level to which it reflects
production again anyone's guess could
change over time so imagine if we could
do this bear with me a second
imagine if you could grab a production
traffic load deploy your new service and
then just magically copy all of that log
traffic and send it to your new service
and that's what we can do with traffic
mirroring so again in this particular
case we can have v1 released and all the
traffic going there and then out-of-band
we can copy all of that traffic and send
it to v2 but the trick here is it's sent
out-of-band so again even if this fails
horribly the user won't be affected or
even aware that it's happening and what
this will also do is then append on a -
shadow suffix to the host and authority
meta header in HTTP so again that
service could actually identify that
this is shadowed traffic so again if
there was gonna be a mutation that would
happen later on in the process
it could say don't apply it or again
idempotent services again you can apply
that with retry policies as well okay so
let's take a look at what that would
look like okay so to do this we're going
to actually trail the logs of each of
these services so first of all what we
do from here is again with coop couple
is select best and they just look at the
logs for each of these so we have v1 at
the top and then we have v2 below so
first of all what I'm gonna do is just
make sure that I'm just sending traffic
to v1 and then as I as I'm sending
traffic again you can just see all of it
v1 and
you can see that the logs across the top
will be tikki along but we won't see
anything then coming through okay so
what we'll actually do here is is I'll
just update the host header just so you
can see it refresh
so we'll say do so again v1 is updating
nothing going to v2 as yet but again
with this policy what we can do now is
update that all that traffic to be
mirrored from v1 to v2 and now suddenly
what you see is all of this traffic
being copied across but the - shadow
being suffix to the end as well and this
is all still deployed we haven't
released this yet so even though is
representative of production traffic it
is actually shadowed so none of our
users will actually be affected even if
service - filled out of the heap and
again with canary releases so so this is
where we actually want to send
production traffic to it so we've
mirrored our traffic we've got a lot of
confidence that yep this looks good
you'll press the button but again from a
risk adverse perspective we might still
say well something might happen so let's
say you could either do it to a pilot
group of users or again just a
percentage of traffic so we've already
seen this where as we did a straight
hundred percent swap you could easily do
five percent or 95 percent I actually
don't think we are too far away from
like a rolling update policy where we
could say why it started at 2%
keep ratcheting it up every five or 10
minutes when you reach 100% nucleolus
and away we go
like that would absolutely be incredible
if you come up with any errors then
that's fine just rewrote to the original
policy as well okay so circuit breakers
are table stakes for distributed systems
so any outbound call from your system to
another
Froese rapid in a circuit breaker
otherwise you're potentially making
matters worse for that downstream
service if it's still struggling to
cater for the amount of load and you
just keep sending traffic to it then
that's just likely making matters worse
but at the same time as responding
slowly then you could do your users a
favor by saying nah I'm just not
comfortable with how that's performing
so I'm gonna return a canned value or
even a more timely error back it's
preferable as well so what we look to do
here is we've now released v2 and we can
look at our in a demo that we'll just
route traffic 50/50 between those two
services
but then we'll introduce service C and
service C then we'll throw errors so but
at the same time in this example it's
deterministic I literally have a throw
if you look at the code it always fails
but in realized that could be for any
number of reasons maybe part of the
infrastructure or a firewall rule got
changed any one of those policies but it
suddenly starts throwing errors but what
we'd like to be able to do with that bid
is prevent that error from permeating
the rest of our system as well and
restore good service as quickly as
possible so let's see it let's take a
quick example of that so again we can
just send traffic across so this stay in
this says no what I'm gonna do is first
of all just send it to the live version
so this will just do 50/50 load
balancing between version 1 and version
2 and then what we're gonna do is we're
going to include service C and a boom
we're suddenly seeing errors coming back
as well but again that this is happening
in the middle of the noise then if
someone gonna be on call to fix this
what we'd like is a system to be able to
identify this and then remove the
erroneous nodes from that availability
pool so in sto nomenclature it's an
outlier detection so what we'll see here
is when we press this I've set up the
rule to
except by request so it's got to be five
consecutive errors and in that case it's
got to be removed from the pool for a
period of twenty seconds so you'll see
those error just going through there and
now it's back to v1 and v2 so in a
couple of seconds what you'll see is
another five errors come through on this
this console and what we're doing there
is it's actually going to recheck first
of all after 20 seconds and then it's
going to do an exponential back-off so
it's gonna be a product of that time by
the number of times it's been removed
from the pool so that way again even if
it's a transient or intermittent error
we'll remove with initially and then
check later odd but at the same time
we're just going to do more and more
conservative checks after that and again
what we can do is just update the policy
again to just be let's just say live
versions and any of the exclusions then
would be removed so again if you update
the policy you can just bring it
straight back in if you wanted to again
afterwards but again I haven't had to do
anything from here and again I can have
all those circuit breakers across all of
my services timeout for all of my
services applied via this policy and
have it pushed up to all of those
services without having to deploy them
okay so this is a bit that really
excited to be and I think it's gonna be
an area that we're seeing a lot more
over the next year so if you want to
speak at a conference I think this will
be a massively topical subject so what
we're really doing here though is
accepting that again we don't know it
all
it's non-deterministic in terms of how
our systems will fail in production so
you can think of chaos engineering or
chaos testing as exploratory testing of
the non-functional characteristics of
your systems such that those
characteristics fail your system is no
longer functional right so but what
we're actually doing here is doing
experiments so to say in production
let's actually generate faults so I
could enjoy
errors into my system and seal with
behaves so if anyone's again read over
the years of our chaos monkey or simian
Arabi that's the very same idea so can I
take a note out of this availability
pool and still have the service remain
up up - can I nuke an entire data center
and have the quality of my service
remain up what we're doing here though
is doing an application level so in this
particular example we have service a
we'll call a and B and then C calls down
to service D as well but we've got to
run the experiment we're gonna say if I
inject 25% of errors on that downstream
leg from C to B power how the system
respond like do we have any policy in
place that will compensate for those
errors
so what we've got to do here is roll
that policy and you'll see now each one
of those legs we're sort of seeing
slightly intermittent so you know every
episode eight or so so that's 25% of of
50 but what we'll see here is we'll take
a quick look as graph are there as well
and this actually Cubs free with we're
basically out of the box with this do as
well so all other instrumentation
instantly gets sent from each one of
those policies gathered back up into
mixer and then display that this
dashboard so what we can see though is
pretty much that we have again
92% of our requests passing but again
our system isn't compensating for that
injected fault so what could we do about
that so what we could do here is
wouldn't it be really nice if service
see again because that call down to D is
idempotent to just retry it again and if
it fails maybe for it into beta they're
just retry that again so what in this
particular case what we'll do here is
again still with injecting the fault
will do a retry policy so that will be
if service see the text that the
downstream call has failed it's gonna
try up to three more times and what we
do in the retry policy is well is we've
also reduced the timeout for that as
well so instead of the default 15
seconds which you get out of the box
I've just said it's gotta be two seconds
so again we're just being a bit more
conservative to say well if that call
fails tried a few more times but after
that you could then have potentially the
circuit breaker pick it as well if we
can't compensate to a retry policy and
what we can now see is even though we're
still injecting the faults we're
actually retrying those calls so again
we'll see this chat go back up to a
hundred percent from here and I wouldn't
keep injecting those faults but run
these as experiments across your system
and another really nice thing that we
could do from here is because sto knows
all of the traffic that's flowing
between all
my services you can get things like
architecture diagrams for free so why
generate these yourself if we know the
shape of all the traffic that flows
through it we can then see what's the
actual shape of my system and then start
drilling in so this is just one
potential visualization but you could do
dot graph or any other formats as well a
number of them so again you put into
your graphing tool of choice but with
the with these systems that change so
rapidly trying to create an accurate
architecture diagram to any level of
fidelity is an exercise in futility we
can have these generated for us though
and the other thing is what so far as
I've been doing everything with policies
so it's been applied to everything but
what I could do as well is apply
specific instructions to a single
request so we can send HTTP headers as
documented on the invoice site that will
then allow me to override those policies
for a particular request so you might be
able to say for this particular user
actually see what would happen if I
reduce the timeout to one second instead
of fifteen seconds but you didn't want
to do it as a policy across you know
across all of your services as well so a
key point here is service measures
enable us to decouple traffic management
from infrastructure scaling so
kubernetes gives us absolutely amazing
abstractions at the infrastructure layer
so docker abstracts us from the
operating system kubernetes abstract us
from the entire infrastructure layer to
take one workload and one cloud provider
and roll it on another cloud provider
kubernetes gives us nothing at layer
seven and that's a lot of concerns that
we as application developers have and
this is where service measures play so
this is about application level value on
top of those at the infrastructure layer
that first of all containerization ed
then kubernetes gave itself but we have
them as
concerns that we could treat them
correctly as separate considerations
okay so service meshes as parents of an
infrastructure lyric or conceptual
infrastructure layer are typically
supported by a platform team within an
enterprise so again making sure that the
service itself is robust resilient so
pop quiz given it's gonna be supported
by service developers do application
developers even need to be aware that
the service mess exists who thinks yes
who thinks no it's always a trick
question
[Laughter]
so I get Jake reps had a quote I really
like about micro services back at 2014
and I don't know if anyone else has
experience with distributed objects but
again with this great idea back in the
j2ee space where we could have these
objects and I call a method of them and
that method might actually result in a
network halt or just to another object
in there so we completely abstracted
that away no surprise that was an
absolute disaster because you couldn't
have any empathy about how costly an
operation would be you just didn't know
what would happen so at the same time
from here is while the service itself
will be supported by a centralized team
with dedicated expertise service
developers should be aware of the
configuration for your services as well
so you will still own the configuration
of your services just not the platform
on which it runs as well so the question
though is called these service measures
are amazing how do I get started slowly
so again another quote from William
Morgan and he's basically saying that
there's a lot of hype around service
measures today some of it may be
well-founded other might just be
hyperbole and we'll have a - broken
dreams in a year's time but what he's
really saying is don't start with a
service mission if he's starting
Greenfields project you probably don't
want to reach for a service message
right off the bat get users make them
happy deliver value if then your
services are representing quite a high
cost of ownership you're spending a lot
of time just trying to understand how
they operate that's where a service mesh
plays really nicely and there is a bit
of a shift in the industry around this
so link Rd was notoriously difficult to
configure there was a huge raft of
valleys and you could have played it was
quite daunting when you looked at the
configuration file if you look at what
Boyer deeds have done with cons with
more recently renamed to liquidy - it
takes a fer leader approach and allows
only like a couple of valleys to be set
at a time but again gradual adoption so
my voice there will be start with a
single capability don't try to have it
do everything on day one instrumentation
is a good one because it generally runs
out of bed so do that have your services
Center laboratory have it displayed on
your dashboards start generating some of
the architecture diagrams from the
content as well and then once you've
understood how to operate that and you
grow some capability or experience in
that area
then move on to the next capability and
so on and so forth
okay so takeaways a service mesh is a
dedicated infrastructure layer making
service to service communications safe I
want to say service the service
communication I'm talking about or PC
and obviously is Paris of a far wider
integration challenge it's not a
solution for everything but it is a very
important piece of the puzzle if you're
micro services are representing a
challenge to operate at the cost of
ownership is high and you're spending
too much time on trying to make just run
and not a build then again a service
mesh can help with some of that friction
and service meshes afford gradual
adoption you can start with a small
piece then proceed on to the next one
and so on and so forth take advantage of
this it's an incredibly powerful
capability
okay we have about six minutes for
questions so the question is I'll just
repeat it back and hopefully that I've
got the rise there I sense so again with
microservices is it still okay to have
some of the services which are running
on the mesh or running on let's say
kubernetes with its do side care is
injected across to other services in
your fleece which don't have that access
yeah absolutely so what are the parrots
with service meshes is you can still put
in like a service entry which will be
egress from the mesh so you can still
absolutely interface with things outside
of like that mesh as well and yeah
that's that's very typical yeah so again
that that's actually logic that you
build into that service entry point as
well where you're gonna say internally
we're gonna resolve it to this within
externally that will then be the DNS
entry outside of the mesh from there
but yeah it's particularly the feature
you're looking for it's called service
entry as opposed to virtual services
which we do to configure for each one of
the policies for those particular
services hi
great question so what you would have so
the question was with traffic shadowing
if you have a new version of the service
but it shares a persisted store do you
then have to compensate for potentially
that action being applied twice so for
instance if you're doing an event
sourcing model you wouldn't want the
same event to be persisted in your log
twice but you would have noticed as well
is that the shadow traffic had - shadow
suffix on each one of those requests as
well so in that particular logic you
would then see in your app to say this
is shadows traffic don't actually write
to the database from there yeah there's
always gonna be sly trade-offs with in
terms of traffic shadowing so you're
correct you have to be aware not of the
mesh but the fact that your traffic is
being shadowed so we have time for one
more question
so the question is how new is sto is a
safe to use the production and what
alternatives would you have in the
market so sto reached v1 back in August
and it has a number of huge backers
behind it including Google so that's
quite a mature offering we also have
linker D which has been released for
about 18 months now
I believe so that's incredibly
battle-tested and mature so it actually
runs on the JVM and typically a
deployment for that would be a would be
a little bit different because it runs
on the JVM it's actually quite heavy so
what we would do with that is typically
not have sidecars injected into each one
of the pods but rather we'd run them as
a daemon set on so at each host but we
would still have ingress and egress
through that David host through to the
other services boss particularly from
there so link D is another option and we
also have a link for d2 as well now so
there's probably your main ones okay so
I think we're out of time thank you so
much for coming to this talk I really
hope you enjoyed it